what number can you add 2x squared minus
6x to complete the perfect square
trinomial so trinomial is just a
polynomial with three terms so right now
we have two terms so they're essentially
saying can we add a term here
essentially a number constant so that
this becomes a perfect square the
expression once it becomes a trinomial
becomes a perfect square so let me just
rewrite it here x squared minus 6x so
we're going to add something right over
here so that the entire expression can
be a perfect square a perfect square of
a binomial and to think about that let's
think about what a perfect square would
look like and so let's imagine let's
imagine if we had something like X plus
a X plus a squared what would that look
like if we would expand it out let me do
this in another color to show you that
this is kind of a little bit of a side
note so let me do it in blue so if I had
X plus some constant a squared well this
is the same thing as X plus a times X
plus a and this is the same thing as you
might remember this pattern or we'll
just multiply it out we'll just multiply
every term here by every term here so x
times X is x squared then x times a is a
X then a times X is a X then we have a
times a is a squared and that all just
comes out of doing the distributive
property twice or you can think of it as
foil if you find that a little bit
easier although that's a little bit more
mechanical and this gives you x squared
plus 2ax plus a squared so if you have a
trinomial in this form it's a perfect
square and it can be factored into X
plus a squared and we see the pattern
here and both in this case and in this
case the coefficient on the x squared
term is one and then we see whatever the
coefficient whatever the coefficient
here is on the first degree term on the
X whatever that coefficient is if we
take half of that number and square it
and make that the constant then this
will be a perfect square for example
half of 2a is a and we're squaring a
right over here and that makes this a
perfect square so let's do the exact
same thing with our binomial
soon to be a trinomial let's look at the
first degree coefficient it is a
negative six you could view this right
over here as our 2a and so what is half
of this or another way to think of it is
2a is equal to negative six if we just
pattern match right over here so what
would a be a would be equal to a would
be equal to negative three and so if we
added a squared to this to this
expression right here it would be a
perfect square so we literally just took
half of this which is negative 3 and
then we're going to square it so
negative 3 squared is positive 9 so this
right over here is just a squared notice
I called this 2a I took half of it to
figure out what a is and I squared it to
get this 9 here so I just took negative
6 divided by 2 is negative 3 squared it
got 9 and if you wanted to factor this
out we have x squared minus 6x plus 9 so
what two numbers when you take their
product you get 9 and when you add them
together you get negative 6 well
negative 3 and negative 3 so this is
going to be X minus 3 times X minus 3 or
you could think of it as X minus 3
squared so it is a perfect square
trinomial